you read recently by a famous Ukrainian
poet about
it's called take only what's important
and it's the poem about leaving home
fleeing the things you will never see
again and it ends with powerful words
that I think we have some audio or video
of I'd like to play that and then talk
oh that's great it's a great poem
the noise
and the unedited lists of the Dead
so long that there won't be enough time
to check them
for your own name
it was
profoundly moving because
99 of the people into focused were
listening and watching were from the
Ukraine so it was so difficult to say
that poem to them
um because basically the poem is saying
you know you might never get home again
it was it was very very difficult and
very moving